this show is sponsored by betterhelp
when you're at your best you can do
great things but sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed
or like you're not showing up in the way
that you want to if you want to live a
more empowered life therapy can get you
there
visit betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today
to get 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash trash Tuesday Daily
Harvest Works directly with Farmers to
Source the best ingredients freezes them
at Peak ripeness to lock in flavor and
nutrients and they never use artificial
preservatives or ingredients if eating
well is a goal for 2023 let Daily
Harvest support you on the journey go to
dailyharvest.com trash Tuesday to get up
to forty dollars off your first box
that's
dailyharvest.com trash Tuesday for up to
forty dollars off your first box
dailyharvest.com trash Tuesday
foreign
[Music]
did you guys read the New York Times
article talking [ __ ] on like Nick Kroll
and hasamanage and no and
um who else uh like Kurt braunhaller and
um with our friend he's coming to
regular ooh married to an manager
um Matt brauner they did this whole this
guy it's like I hate these pieces like
you're allowed to criticize comedians
they're like oh these these dad Comics
doing like hacky dad material it's like
you're a lot it's your special you can
do whatever you want wait who who is the
writer I have no clue who this person is
but he's obviously not a comedian but
it's like and then he was like he was
like but I loved the way like Jenna
Freeman and someone else did there but
it was like not I haven't seen Jenna's
or anything I'm not like talking on her
but it's like how can it be okay for one
person to do it and not okay for another
person to do it also if you have a kid
and you don't talk about your kid on
stage I actually find that to be almost
child abused like are you not thinking
about your kid but it was just like you
know it's so like hacky or whatever it's
like first of all everything is hacky
that's how I feel it's just like can you
take like a a small twist to a thing
that other people are talking about it's
like also hacky the other side of hockey
is like relatable but it was just like
this weird I just started to get so
defensive because I actually like I mean
I didn't watch I've never watched anyone
so special but I really laughed hard at
nickrel's special and I don't go into
specials I'm a hater I don't go into
specials looking to laugh yeah I go into
specials going like make me laugh well
specials are hard like it doesn't always
translate like I know for a fact there
are things that I could see performed in
real life the the same thing performed
in real life will make me laugh my ass
off and then seeing it on a special I
just wouldn't laugh it's it's weird but
that's how I feel about almost all
special so it's like that's why if a
special can make me laugh at all I'm
like this is especially because we're
like calloused to Comedy yeah in a lot
of ways just because we see it all the
time but it is like a good Testament and
like argument for live comedy being a
thing that is still
its own art form that you can't capture
and translate do you guys think that
um stand-up comedy is Evergreen and
forever or do you think it will take a
new form like you know now it's like
there's so many ways to be funny there's
so many platforms to be funny do you
think that stand-up comedy is gonna
stick around for as long as as it has
already had I do because
of the thing I just said like live any
live performance even though it might
get smaller like look when movies
started becoming big plays became less
popular but there are people still doing
and buying and seeing plays and stuff so
I think do you think you buy the play
buying tickets sorry I bought Chicago
this weekend what have you bought
but can you actually buy it maybe can
you do that like like uh uh football
teams and [ __ ] can you like buy could I
buy Chicago yes so um
um yeah of course
like you know you could either you you
waited for the smart person to say yes
and then you agreed oh you absolutely
can getting sold the Phoenix Suns are
for sale we're talking about you didn't
even listen Magic Johnson bought you
know winning on the Dodgers no no no no
I know that but as like plays yes can
you buy the play you guys don't know
players they're uneducated no it's we're
the Smart Ones that's the only play and
Les Miserables but I was so pissed oh it
was the same thing as you when the
intermission I was livid I thought you
were just asking whether or not you can
buy sports teams oh that's so
embarrassing about wearing it you're
like yes because what's his name um um
oh my god
um Ryan Reynolds and the guy from is it
Rob
yeah him they bought some small football
team from Wales right was that not a TV
show is that real no it's real yeah it's
like a reality show they actually know
they they actually bought this football
team isn't there a TV show about this
too though and it's on Hulu oh okay but
to answer your question says gets mad
sometimes on Hulu no you're unhinged I
like it you're not running with me
honestly it's not flirting it's not
flirting there's nothing going on no I'm
I'm trying to come to terms because it's
like I can like be annoyed by his swings
or I can just lean into them you're
gonna piss on her okay wow sorry Pete
that was bad for YouTube sorry I want to
answer this question because plays are
put on by investors so I feel like the
same way like investors buy a team it's
like you could be like I'm gonna spend
this amount of money and put on a
production of funny girl starring Esther
pavitsky if you wanted I'm just like
whatever it was you crazy what is it
ironic when they say funny
are you the before
[Laughter]
um but okay so with are you I do have
any interest do you not want to talk
about your movie I can't tell because I
would be wanting to talk about
everything but no I don't mind talking
about it but what you said about like
these the critic writing that's yeah
about the stand-up comedians like it
made me think of like
making the movie I was this week I was
sitting there was like wait this is so
weird we're like making this fun
creative thing that like came from our
brains and work sites like play pretend
and it's fun you can kind of cast anyone
you want
the crazy things you do like whatever
you want you can kind of make it happen
that's true that's so weird and so at
the end of it the whole thing is for all
movies
they're to be critiqued there's all
these people that are waiting to
critique it and it's not until like it's
mine that I'm like wait that's messed up
then you go like if it gets bad reviews
you gotta go like ah I I didn't really
do I kind of just was around you know
like you that's when you're just like
when you when it gets good reviews
you're like I did everything it was so
nice of these people to be around doing
what I told them to do now Esther okay
if you could have a movie that was like
if you had two options
no wait this isn't gonna make sense
because obviously you would pick the
good one but if you had a chance to get
a cult following for having a very bad
movie like a like a room the room do you
remember the room did you ever see it
like that would you but there's no way
because that's like a delusional that
guy was like not self-aware but would
you go for it I don't know what you mean
like okay so if I put something on it's
so bad that it becomes good do I want
that like in my head I'm like maybe I do
like who cares like if it's all just the
same feeds into the same thing we all do
a million things you'll probably make
like 10 movies like this is probably
just one movie I'm not worried about my
movie being like the worst movie that's
ever come out that's not what I mean I
know that's what it sounds like but
that's what I mean but would you as what
she was saying like a fall under five
percent I I would absolutely put money
down to make one like a terrible movie
but then that sort of takes away from it
being a terrible movie because the
genuinely terrible ones are the ones
where you can tell people really wanted
it they had no clue that's why the room
is up because he was so serious right
but also I first my first watch I
thought I was a masterpiece truly just a
comedic Masterpiece well then you
realize he's not kidding well yeah like
the delusion is just so so so so like
palpable that it just it's so funny
everything about that movie is hilarious
do you know what's crazy is I think one
of the first dates I ever actually went
on because I didn't whatever was Tony
taking me to see the room at that in
West Hollywood did you throw spoons he
was like yeah he was like Tony you hack
we and also wait this is so dorky like
early 20s he like was really proud of
like the funny things he would shout out
in the theater so Tony before you had
the number one comedy podcast
he's like I do the number one yell out
at the room
you have you been to West Hollywood then
you know about me and as dorky as it
sounds being like the lame girlfriend of
someone who did that I had to say he was
really funny the fact that I'm just
assuming you were a tag along girlfriend
because I can't imagine he let you speak
it's crazy like were you I feel like you
were Jacob with him and he was just
carrying around on a leash this is
insane Esther are you allowed to talk
about your um past relationships yeah on
error is is that a No-No from Dave uh
well Dave doesn't like it but I don't
care what was it like what's he like is
Tony a good kisser was he good in bed oh
my God
one of your ex-boyfriends told me like
Esther was a friend and then I told you
like ew
said I was a freak yeah she's like she's
a freak I was like oh I don't wanna know
that and then I told you and you're like
ew
it was true
I'm famously a bad kisser so I just want
to everyone knows that right we don't
know that I can tell look at her stupid
idiot
she'll be kissing her ear accidentally
I've told you guys this that after me
and Dave's first kiss like a few like
after you know after we were comfortable
with each other he was like yeah you
seemed like really excited that's how
hot you are he likes
you just open mouth and go wild with a
tongue so you don't close back are you
don't go no I'm just like there's no one
she's trying to get her ass eaten or
something she's like I got plans because
I'm like so excited that I just have to
get in there and there's just so many
like popcorn kernels like getting going
back and forth you guys not kiss that
way no I could really I think I kissed
very average I do just Lip lip then we
just open a little and then yeah
yeah like hot on camera if you were try
if we were kissing we're doing that like
I would bang teeth I would overpower and
I would wait wait wait are you wait are
you like the boy like my first kiss boys
where it's like they just lock open
mouths and then the tongue goes I was
always like you know this isn't like
wait that's Junior
it's like I'm in junior high because
that's when I first kissed so that's how
I learned we do not believe that's when
you first get it I believe it was many
years after so many years wait a second
I'm so confused we find out Esther just
had our first kiss after three years of
Dave no but wait because I'm with a kid
in junior high my question to you is
like is that you kiss that way because
that's how you enjoy it the most or
that's just how you know to do it
because both why do your tits look like
they're back in
oh that's just the negative bra negative
again no I'm actually ovulating so my
tits are smaller than usual see they go
smaller when you're ovulating they suck
in yeah
um closer to my period they really go
like a full cup size up my appetite is
how I know
oh well that too and the 10 pounds and
the everything but it's do you enjoy
kissing that way just locking and
loading yes and have you forced it
because I've had guys that we don't kiss
well together Todd has a nice juicy lips
and it's perfect but like but I've had
boyfriend's where it's like and it's
like you have to like where it's like
it's just we don't have the same style
and you have to like overpower them and
like force your way of kissing onto them
or you have to just take one for the
team and be like I'm just gonna be like
no that's the thing with my style of
kissing is like it's almost like rock
paper scissors like mine beats
everything else it's like mine wait I
want to fight you on this I want to make
out with you and see if you can
overpower save it for the live I feel
like Annie is a good kisser I'm really
worried about you God Todd's into
lesbian porn too I wonder if he's gonna
get a boner that's so cute I love him
wait you should hook up with us like as
a gift to Todd but I don't know if he
would he's like not jealous but he's
like not open to any openness which is
fulfillment it's just like an art
project no one will have feelings I have
you guys I had a boy do this thing once
and I know it sounds really not sexual
at all but he took my palm like just my
palm like this and he started like
tonguing the inside of my palm and I've
never been
I would take that one hand and choke
myself why because it would be so
embarrassing until something licking my
hand you better have the best breath in
the world by the way if I smell that
happen there's any nasty breath in it
[ __ ] you which one's my camera I've
never looked at the right one this one
oh that's soap and I've never looked at
that one
yeah
it's like I have two lazy eyes
my lazy eyes are just wait I okay so I
disagree and I'm don't you feel of
course because you are like think you're
a dog [ __ ] don't you hands are very for
me hands are very sexual yes yes but
also I'm telling you as I grow older the
whole sucking fingers and [ __ ] like you
have to have good breath I can't smell
your nasty breath on don't exclude some
of us if you licked my fingers I would
throw up off your face I would lick it
up I know I'd [ __ ] poke my fingers
out so you throw up too
no but okay this is I'm not gonna say
who but a guy that I was recently around
his son aroused by around oh my God Dave
he
I forgot why like the topic of hands
like we were all joking around about
hands and he just go it was it was like
it was on our shoot it was really late
at night and he goes my girlfriend loves
my hands and I was like that is such a
flex yeah because you know what that
means what he said but the thing is I
think you can tell too I think there
isn't you can go hand first into a guy
also calves but I know that hands I've
never had a guy with good hands that's
not good like with handsome hands it
isn't good using them correct correct
correct correct I like uh working man's
hands like if they're Craftsmen if
they're people that do like woodwork or
like all of these things like you know
but still not too dirty clean your
[ __ ] nose out I don't want to get a
[ __ ] UTI but it's usually guys who
are use their hands a lot that are very
conscious of their hands so I've never
had like a problem with them but the
guys you don't want the guys with the
chewed up thing no offense to you guys
but just because they're anxious so
they're not used to well maybe they're
like
maybe they'll like work well maybe but
yeah guys their fingers are used to
soothe their own anxiety those aren't
the ones I want I think we need to
normalize being like like right before
things are getting intimate a girl just
being like when's the last time you
washed your hands Oh I thought you're
gonna be like I have halitosis
are you guys like being crazy
on purpose
require
um to see an STD
um
you guys require an s3d panel yeah I
want to make sure did you [ __ ] Esther
can you imagine we would never be asking
my sisters
that's interesting I've never been into
the same guy listen no offense to all of
our friends that we know we've all
[ __ ] but we like different types of
losers
when we bugged down it was like
different types yeah
we are I feel like we have crossover
yeah but I would never be into Bobby I
would also have Crossover with Annie
though because some of the boys that she
finds hot I find out so yeah yeah but
you and I will never fight over a guy do
you know what I started laughing about
when you're talking I just had this
complete separate thought where I was
thinking we know for a fact like you did
not get hit on to make your movie like I
know for a fact there was no casting
couch
I've not never like I still get bitter
when I hear about those stories because
I'm like I've been here 13 years no man
has ever like promised me something and
then like leaned in like it's never
happened and I'm I'm like I'm I know
that's not funny in a sense because it's
I feel bad for people that happens too
but one time I think I deserve
a man to desire me and offer me a you
um you're killing Pete over here
[Music]
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
when you're at your best you can do
great things okay but sometimes life
really gets you bogged down you know
it's the start of a new year this is
really a time where I'm just trying to
figure out what my clear path and my
plan is for the year and so therapy is a
really great tool to help me feel
empowered and more prepared to take on
everything that life is going to throw
at me
therapy has changed my life for the
better I cannot stress to you enough how
important and valuable it is especially
just being a freaking person in my 30s
and when I was a person in my 20s same
deal I think it's important for all ages
I just I'm not saying people in their
40s don't need therapy I just haven't
been there yet
if you want to live a more empowered
life therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better help
help.com slash trash Tuesday
Harvest delivers delicious Harvest bowls
soups flatbreads snacks smoothies lattes
and more built on organic fruits and
vegetables Daily Harvest Works directly
with Farmers to Source the best
ingredients freezes them at Peak
ripeness to lock in flavor and nutrients
and they never use artificial
preservatives or ingredients with
nourishing and easy to prep options I
never have to think twice about what to
eat for my next meal snack or dessert
everything stays fresh in my freezer
until I'm ready to enjoy it to helping
me reduce food waste which is a super
important thing that I'm trying to
change about myself this year I love
their artichoke and spinach flatbread
the tomato and zucchini minestrone soup
the broccoli rice and Dill peel off
Harvest Bowl they just have a lot of
really good options I I used to use them
when they were just smoothies but now
they have the food too even better
if eating well is a goal for 2023 let
Daily Harvest support you on the journey
go to dailyharvest.com trash Tuesday to
get up to 40 off your first box that's
dailyharvest.com trash Tuesday for up to
forty dollars off your first box
dailyharvest.com trash Tuesday
but do you ask for STD tests
yeah and you're such a liar the pauses I
do not believe before one percent a
hundred who's waiting long enough to
have a test you go to The Cutting Edge
testing where all the porn girls go
that's where I go it's 12 hours like you
get it right away you get the full panel
you while you blow them before blow them
before
um yeah if I don't see on any obvious
like cold sores on them or whatever oh
my God how about when I was in college
and my boyfriend had one straight here
eating me out I did not understand what
cold sores were yeah but everyone has
herpes type one so it didn't I didn't
get it though I got tested a million
times yeah I mean who knows if I have it
now I have shingles so wait what yeah
shingles are you have them forever it's
herpes yeah but it's um herpes that's um
more like chickenpox herpes herpes
saucer but I don't want to brag no I'm
so jealous now I'm kind of competitive
you have shingles it's like the hottest
herpes it's the coolest herpes it's like
you're like your name of herpes like an
old person type of herpes the only thing
about Herpes is that it just looks
painful like anytime I see someone with
a cold sore I just know they're not
having a good couple weeks don't doesn't
like herpes like I don't I have had a
couple friends with genital herpes
doesn't it like isn't it kind of like
you have one outbreak and the reason you
have it is because you don't realize you
have it yet so you can't do anything to
kind of like not have it but don't you
like not have outbreaks that much yeah I
think from what I understand if you have
herpes type one down there your
outbreaks are more spaced out when you
have herpes type too like the genital
herpes that is based in this area
um it it can be a little bit more
frequent but then if you take like
Valtrex yeah then you suppress that you
know oh my God my friend I remember we
were at this bar
and her valtex bottle rolled out of her
back it rolled the [ __ ] security
guard stopped it with his boots and I
picked it up was like I was like ah I
grabbed it I was like do not read that
out loud I had to take Valtrex when I
had shingles oh you had a tuna yeah I
had it when did you have shingles when I
was 19 years old I was a nursery school
teacher at let's imagine Nursery School
this is what I think is [ __ ] I know
I know that both of you guys have had
shingles how do you not know that either
because you're our nurse [ __ ] do you
think I'd go to her for help with stuff
I would never bring my own ailments to
her I don't want that's your mistake
because I [ __ ] diagnosed you with a
sinus infection but you're busy with
your own sinus infection I don't want to
get in the way of you having a sinus
infection but my side is infection thank
you for that by the way I still cough up
a little phlegm in the morning it's
still not gone it takes a while I
remember having like double pneumonia
when I was 17 and it took a whole year
for me to to feel like my lungs were
normal you had double pneumonia while
you were getting double pneumonia then
you're rehab
mature enough for the word double
did you guys ever get mono the kiss
never oh God did you gave it to so many
people didn't you I didn't have it I
gave it to a girl from sharing a Slurpee
we had an intense Slurpee share and then
she got it I feel bad I'm sorry oh my
God I can only imagine just slobbering
in the Slurpee [ __ ] pig I still don't
know who gave it to me though
is that weird I don't know well I've
been thinking a lot about my college
crabs that I had
it was the funniest thing that's ever
happened to me I feel like everyone
deserves crabs it was so cute it's like
nothing it's like nothing to happen it
was itchy and did burn it was sucked it
was very itchy and they are alive on you
so it's like you see them I could see
them I went to the nurse to get
diagnosed did I tell this one here a
long time ago yeah I want to go to the
nurse story I went to the nurse to get
diagnosed and she didn't diagnose me and
I was like I came she was like no I
don't think you have anything then I
left and I [ __ ] saw them and so I
went back I was like aren't they so
nasty looking
oh I think that kind of just gagged why
do you think it's because you smell your
own breath I think they look kind of
cute keep them as pets did you get a
whiff wait did you guys see someone like
science released a photo of ants yes oh
nasty yeah
was like posting about it I was like oh
you got to stop I saw it on Tick Tock
I'm so scared of them I do like them
it's got to be a joke it looks like
terrifier
like it looks the same it's true they
did release it right around Halloween
it's like they're so full of [ __ ] I
would need to see more than one of those
it kind of makes me respect the ant I'm
like all right bro like all right I see
you yeah but it's like how pathetic is
that like slobbery thing we could just
step on it it's done no my dad would
always like he'd be like don't kill bugs
don't kill ants he'd be like you know
how hard it is you could never make an a
creature like that he would like shame
me that I wasn't able to make an ant or
was he like like you can't make them or
he's like I bet you a quarter he's just
like gambling with you
I bet you a whole quarter all of a
sudden your dad's got all your [ __ ]
allowance
I realize now that um I was used and
exploited as a kid now I know I already
knew that we knew that nuts actually but
when I was younger there was this game
this card game in the Philippines it's
kind of like a poker game that
apparently I was a whiz at and I started
playing at the age of five I feel like
the poker games that you played were
actually like
poke poke her poked her oh sorry let's
keep going I interrupted so we're so
um but um my family would um whoever it
was they'd be like oh we got kalila
today they would they would have called
dibs on me and they would sit me on
their lap and it was like a three or
four person game and I would play on
their behalf and we would gamble so I
actually started gambling for money like
the age of six because I was so good at
it and to this day no one in my family
can beat me they try we will play 20
games and it's 20-0
guys there's nothing wrong with gambling
sorry that your dad thinks there's a
problem there I think it's great gamble
like kids but nothing was given to me I
never got any Kickback like hey here's
like a dollar for they just sat me on
their lap and I played the card game and
they do you see how you're like us
you're like a super intelligent person
it's Filipino poker I don't know if that
that means super intelligence it's a
very basic game but when I was little I
ha or actually not little but in high
school I have this form what is it
called core memory of when my parents
and I went to San Francisco and
we were walking on the street and we saw
this guy playing three card Monty but
you know the one where it's like what uh
under what cup is the ball they're like
doing that that you've seen yeah right
and there's all these people gathering
around watching and then they put the
cup over you and he goes which cup is
she on and then I never saw myself again
no and then so my dad brought me over
and he was like okay I want you to watch
this like he's like and so we stood
there like to the side watched everyone
playing and he's like so that person is
working with the guy and this is and
then the guy who is playing the game
goes teacher at home and it was like it
was such a formative like fun memory
because I just felt like I was like in
it and like oh my God like my dad was
right and the guy like wanted us out of
there it was very is this sad get in
trouble with your dad yeah at the same
time yeah that's so cute because you
probably looked at him like oh my God he
knows I knew we're doing bad things with
him like gambling's kind of bad you know
yeah naughty things were you stealing
tiny shampoos from hotels my dad and I
would um oh I'll do you one better all
of my utensils to this day are all
stolen from Outback Steakhouse
so in college when I was broke I
couldn't and I moved into an apartment
with a couple people I couldn't afford
utensils so and you can afford Outback
anytime someone like so when my stepdad
on my birthday was like hey let's go to
Outback I'd be like yeah sure I like
those knives that they stick in the Box
yep I took all of them I still have them
are they they I bet they're oh do you
have those I probably do know wait did
you guys ever buy maybe go or sell Cutco
knives yes yes yes yes yes yes in high
school yeah did you sell them my sister
did oh my God I do not want you with
knives to be honest as a kid oh my God
that was what you would have been sliced
up so much I was slicing up everything
but I would use safety pins I was like
an extreme cutter so sad so emo cut me
knives buy my cut me knives wait what do
you know about cut cocoa knives we are
Jesse Eisman there were some um yeah it
was like the Avon like knives yeah and
my mom would buy the [ __ ] out of them my
mom was like come on and Jesse was
always like a kid from her little league
team like come on in we're buying all
your knives you're like she'd stop at
like the top tier like I can't but they
were great knives they were great knives
we put Jesse through college Jesse
Richmond like that guy yeah Cutco knives
what a deep cut I remember those did you
guys ever get entrepreneurial as teens
and like sell things what I made
um
um maxi pads that my homemade Maxi pass
oh my God
what I wasn't a teenager I was um
probably nine and I was obsessed with
getting my period
I mean I was obsessed with never getting
my period no no I had a I had a friend
who was obsessed with periods in third
grade she like would make the teacher
talk to us about puberty all the time
she was like obsessed with it you were
the puberty obsessed I was I was afraid
of puberty I was in college you're like
Professor tell me more about periods
because I was afraid of puberty because
it was like drilled into my head that
the moment I started my period my
swimming career was over oh my God that
trail of blood because you had only had
pads yeah that trail of blood down the
[ __ ] sharks coming right up another
thing I did in elementary school was I
would
um people would pay me to go run like
buy their lunch for them or be like hey
um
and I was just like a runner I guess you
were like a Carlos I was a Carlos yeah I
was the first Postmates original
Postmates I
was totally that girl that when my best
friend got her first period
I was so like couldn't wait to get mine
like I felt so much fun do you think
it's because you were like at the level
of her period you're at the height
opposite wait did she seem happier when
she got it seemed it seemed just
Dreadful too but it was like oh my God
my best friend has it like I want to be
like her I I'm left out I'm left behind
like I can't wait how much sooner did
she get hers than you not that much
maybe only like six months to a year I
definitely was I was next in the friend
group so I got lucky I got my period
just decades before everyone else I mean
I was just so much bigger than everyone
I was taller than everyone I was always
like a giant compared to what grade were
you in I was 11. that is Young I was
like well girls are getting them eight
nine now and my and I only had brothers
and my mom like I was trying to be a boy
so I got him in my umbros I was in
umbros
I was in music class I got mine actually
on the first date I ever went on in
sixth grade with this boy who I was so
upset so I was really excited for this
date and my sister crimped my hair for
me and when I got to school he was like
I don't think you should do that to your
hair again and you're like did you think
I did it I have a servant
and then we went on our date and when I
got home and then like I saw thank God I
didn't discover the period till
afterwards but I got home and I was like
there's blood and I was like she just
walked in opened a drawer and just like
here
and that's where you became pad girl yes
that was the moment my mom was like
tampons all the way she's like you're
not quitting swimming that's when I get
a break after school so you're going to
swim team we had to I had to swim
through all of my periods but tampons
right yeah yeah it's so unhealthy you
get it uh closer to 14. what do you mean
it's unhealthy it's bad to have the
chlorine in there stop it up imagine
like it being healthy to put a tampon
while you're in the water why I don't
know it just now when I go swimming and
I'm on my period I don't wear a tampon I
just take it out because yeah just free
bleed into the water do you remember
insteads
what's dead look up insteads insteads
what is that as I used to wear them as
bracelets as a joke they were like the
first like it was before they had like
Diva cups and stuff so you could [ __ ] on
your period oh and they were like pink
like
um
they're like pink like rubber things and
then it's like a plastic
thing yeah they're kind of so big the
first time a boy ever fingered me and
this is
um one of my smaller traumas it doesn't
really it's not a teacher no no no it
was a boyfriend the first time a boy
fingered me this why it's messed up is
because I was only 12 he was 19. um but
um I one of the creepiest things in
hindsight or maybe I thought it done too
was when he was like because I was like
he would always ask me do you have your
period yet yeah are you a woman yet and
I'm like I don't have it I don't have it
yet and then the day that I got my
period he was the first person I called
to be like I'm I'm you know I finally
got my period and he congratulated me
and gave me like a gift basket oh my God
that's really nice this is cute it was
like the nicest thing that's ever
happened to you like this is the nicest
anyone treated you as a child what it's
no also what I said as an adult you said
no and then you're like he was 19 and
still an adult he's a 19 year old
fingered I blew him he was the first
person I blew yeah how old were you 12.
how old were you that's what you just
said [ __ ] up thing is like I'm like
jealous like I wanted to be like like
that when I was well the thing is you
can be 12 still you're the only one in
this room that could be 12 if you really
want Esther you tried hard enough I had
a mouth full of braces I my hair is
really this is when you know that she's
getting more jealous she's like I didn't
get to have a mouthful of braces a meat
grinder it's [ __ ] up
it it is but then I did get a whole
basket of really ripe mangoes that day
and I was like he was like you're a
woman now I was like thank you
yeah it was really weird to be like to
engage in anything sexual before your
period no my friend my friend in middle
school would bang she didn't have her
period yet yeah she would bang in the
her and her boyfriend was that word when
talking about a middle schooler yes
that's when we called it in middle
school
I feel like you skipped Middle School
junior high what did you call it banging
is the most Middle School word really
what would you call it making love
I remember being so disgusted when
someone said making love no that is no
no I love it now no I love it now it is
not worse now I grew into it I now at
this age I'm like no wonder there's a
gross adults have been saying it forever
it makes me hot and horny well sometimes
you are that's like making baby type of
banging where you're just like shot to
outer space that's like cry [ __ ] oh I
you know what I cried I I mean that
turns out I still cry after sex and I'm
really ashamed I cry dying sometimes no
you don't I do okay Annie is it a deep I
like I get like so I get really me too I
shake cry it's the whole thing and I'm
apologizing as I'm crying and I'm like
look it's it's this just happened I did
not apologize it's not I know you're
welcome Todd Todd I've made your life
very beautiful you're welcome wait
there's a couple theories around it okay
um some some people say it's some type
of like repressed some sexual something
other people think it it had nothing to
do it's just something your body does
when you feel like some type of release
but there's multiple theories around it
can you look it up Carlos what are you
guys doing I think I feel like so
connected it's not like with everyone
it's like I think it's just like you
know with Todd it's like I just feel
like it's such a kind of a relief to
have like a loving just like my guy you
know is are they going slow no it's for
me it's after coming so immediately
after coming I am bawling my eyes out
I know it's weird but I'll like be
embarrassed during if I'm crying like
during see but during it's really sweet
and all no I feel like I'm such a hippie
I get like so connected and I think
that's why it was really when I was
being a little more promiscuous I had
like uh famously with you guys know
about when I dated this guy a little bit
on and off and I felt a little bit
played by him I was so like hurt that he
I was like we could have just been
friends it's like I'm not I'm like a
vulnerable person when I [ __ ] so it's
like it's frustrating when I'm like you
knew you were playing me
and you put like we just could have not
done that right so frustrating a little
side note it's human nature for women to
be vulnerable when they have sex like
that is you become chemically attached
to the person like it's that's your
brain chemistry it's not even you I
wanted to ask you guys we talked about
this on tigerbelly briefly um with Nikki
but we didn't talk about it in depth um
do you when you first date a guy do you
gatekeep your friends from him or do you
bring him in almost immediately to meet
your friends and why or why not I've
never kept anyone I wouldn't even occur
it would not even occur to me I'd I roll
through life I Barrel through life so
when you met no players no rules
actually you're right because when you
even when you were in the beginning
stages of toddy you were bringing him
around everywhere I think with the
internet I will just because I don't
want people to like of course of course
attack them or whatever or not even
attack them I just don't know if I want
to bring them into my story
I feel like I should have gate kept my
friends from Dave like
I I just I would Pummel you if you sit
in front of a gate I would knock you I
would [ __ ] like because I my life was
such a mess that like we Dave and I
still laugh about like why didn't you
break up with me like I was sharing the
studio apartment with like you know a
woman who is like a little a little
silly
um she's just got a funny personality is
she in the movie we're still friends
she's in the movie yeah I love her
um but
like I do feel like
that yeah I know I lost my channel can I
get a credit at the end that just as
Andy Letterman wasn't in this movie yes
thank you I actually really like both
not pictured Annie Letterman I like both
of your approaches because what I find
really really high pressure is when I
haven't met someone's friends and now
we've been dating six months and now
there's a formal meeting that to me is
like oh God like now I have to impress
when it's uh our friends yeah like come
that's what pissed me off with that one
guy because he was like holding my hand
in public and stuff and I don't want
like if people figure out who this is
this is not me like coming after anyone
I have no interest in having any more
weird dramas with [ __ ] anyone I swear
to God everyone is like fine and doing
great and I'm happy for everyone but the
thing that pissed me off with this guy
was we
we went on some dates it was like very
flirty we went on some dates he was
trying to hold my hand in front of
people we knew it was like very weird
then
um we did hook up and then he was like
I want you to meet my friends and so he
like set up like a bowling with all of
his friends and then I'm like all right
so then right before we go to meet his
friends he calls me he goes hey I just
want to let you know I'm seeing other
people so like and I'm like you are
pushing this forward so then the whole
time I'm like I'm so already like just
naturally prone to being anxiously
attached yeah so I was just like the UN
yes veg the unlike that's what our name
should have been anxiously attached
um
I my name is Annie and I'm anxiously
attached but um it was just like it was
the mixed messages were driving me
[ __ ] crazy and the truth is this
person is mixed up in their head right
like their head is all [ __ ] up so
that's not my problem
um I thought about me but it was hard to
not take it personally because it was
like what the hell and it just would be
like because your emotions got [ __ ]
with yeah yeah but I love bringing um
new people to meet my friends almost
immediately because they're able to
maybe pick up on things that like I'm
not picking up on but also I really
trust my friends to not be judgy [ __ ]
they're just like yeah this is a guy
she's dating they're not putting any
extra with him yeah oh my God imagine a
friend flirting no my friends that's
like my high school friends would be
like [ __ ] them in the bathroom I'm
like wait what this is my boy that's
crazy that's funny I had the Cuckoos in
high school yeah no but like bringing
them around enough like to be able to
like observe how they move and without
like it's really such a low pressure
because he's you're nothing to each
other yet yeah so you they almost kind
of like grow into the family if it
becomes serious and there's more there's
an ease around that right yeah well I
just never like I'll bring all my mix
all my friends I never really have like
a problem mixing worlds or like keeping
I I remember my friend in high school
she was always like worried about this
is a good this was a good friend she
wasn't a crazy one but she was always
like cautious of mixing worlds
I okay this is I feel like my most
animalistic Instinct and I wonder if it
is right or if I should let go of it but
it's based on an interaction obviously
that I had early on when I was like 21
where a girl
I've talked about this before like a
girl touching my boyfriend in front of
me
I'm like I know what you're doing you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
not like it at all well it's just it's
so annoying it's because it's there are
these types of that same [ __ ] did that
to me it's habitual line steppers they
know they're trying you know what's
behind those eyes stand up yeah like so
if I am her and you're my boyfriend it's
just like
or this they'll crack an inside joke
that you're not a party but don't you
love that we're all talking about the
exact same girl and by the way this
[ __ ] I remember when I was dating me
when I was doing my accent here's the
thing my ex he like I'm telling you he
was like such like a love addict and he
was like texting like 50 girls I love
you and I I wasn't jealous for some
reason like I never was jealous of him
like I kind of always knew like whatever
was gonna happen was gonna happen with
us but I I never got jealous even though
he was such like a like he just like I
don't know I don't know why but so this
girl we were at The Comedy Store and
this girl was like
like just trying to talk about sex with
him and like leaning into all this stuff
and we were like laughing in her face
like we're like looking at each other
like what the [ __ ] and he's like the
thing is this girl's so unhot like she
thinks like physically she's a pretty
girl but like she's so un actually hot
like as a person like she thinks she's
like trying to be this hot thing and she
was talking about like lesbian
experiences in front of him and stuff
and he was just like I mean we were just
like ugh that's our actual pick me like
I know we joke about what a pick me is
but that's it but it's also at us but it
was at us it was like not for them it
was like us hey I knew exactly what you
mean or they will talk about things that
make it seem like they've known each
other longer than you that's it your
partner and then like shut up like his
dick was just in my mouth like this one
this person it's like is no competition
like all competition but no competition
you know what I mean like since I met
this person constantly trying to compete
with me
I don't share the same feelings as you I
don't see you as competition I think I
do a very different thing than you and
if you want to try to battle me you will
continue to lose like I don't know what
to say yeah it's like pissing even if
you think you're winning it's like I
wasn't going anything you get I wasn't
going for right you know what I mean and
it's like I dared [ __ ] my ex-boyfriends
I don't want to bug them
but girls like we love you but don't be
that do not be that it's weird it's like
that's weird because if I saw either of
you guys touching and rubbing up on Dave
I wouldn't care Esther you've asked
rubbing up on Davis that's so funny
imagine I'm just like hiding I really
imagine that world I remember you being
so high at Bobby's 50th birthday party
and Dave was across from us right so it
was you me I think Annie here next to me
and a day was a cross Gina Gershon
randomly randomly there and you were
high out of your mind and you were like
Lila like really louder like Kyla will
you please [ __ ] Dave you were great that
was a real fun hit that was that was fun
and then poor day was like Esther he was
so mad at you and then Jenna was like oh
[ __ ] Dave she's like no not you
enough Jenna we know
but she was like doing that as your
friend yeah she was like no I'll do it
for you and Esther had just had no
answers you were like no not you kalila
that's such a weird creepy projection of
me wanting to have sex with you it's
like I'll somehow get it if you have sex
with him
very strange world that was such a fun
hangover you know what I do like though
I do like about you guys every time I've
met like girls you're friends with it's
very easy and friend like you have like
good taste in girls like Jenna and I I
feel like Jenna and I didn't like it
took us like a one or two hangs but it's
like I feel totally comfortable with
Jenna you're but you and Jenna are both
people that just Dive Right In right
correct perfectly so we almost like
missed because it was like maybe too
divy we like hit heads and like sunk and
now we're both in like Comas in the
hospital Jenna fits in every room yeah
so I it's I never have to worry about
like any time I need a companion and I
worry about where I'm going yeah I bring
her because it's like she just fits in
yes she's so great and she's just so
charismatic and funny yeah yeah and then
so see I feel the same about it's like
so she's easy as [ __ ] easy I gotta say
like I feel really lucky about my girl
gang give me that banana I'm so hungry
foreign
this is supposed to be a [ __ ] green
green I mean
but I guess green bananas are good for
digestion so yeah they're from Air one
you're good
also why I want these to come out of
your what you smell like Hairspray
it's your hair dum-dum you got your hair
done is it probably
your braid just like wafted in front of
you I watched this thing that kept me up
for two straight days once and it was a
documentary about how we might we might
soon not have bananas
and I went into a full scale panic
because these types of bananas are
called Cavendish bananas and they're the
most marketable ones because they look
like pretty that's the skin doesn't
Brown
um very quickly but there's actually a
hole like in the Philippines I grew up
with like six different types of bananas
right but they're wiping all of those
varieties brother banana the teacher
bananas
they're delicious
um
but because these are the most like
marketable or look prettiest on the
shelves they keep pushing for these but
there is this parasite that wipes entire
Farms Out and because now we lack in
variety we lack in variety of bananas
but she doesn't eat on the podcast she
makes up for it
and yeah you guys like we gotta watch
out for a banana Supply because if these
run out I'm definitely leaving this
Earth I'm about to cry because of what
that's triggering I'm literally welling
up did you hear about what's
what got canceled for this season
wait what do you mean they're canceling
crab legs Curtis Carlos what's your name
put it up pull it up Curtis Curtis is
actually a way cooler name than Carlos
for a decade it's a way cooler I was
just thinking of a cooler person but go
ahead what do you mean no one named
Curtis Hanson but he's dead there's no
who's Curtis Hanson Curtis Stone
director made LA Confidential he's an
Oscar winner oh my God
you can keep
no I want the world to see what Carlos
is really like they know I want people
to see the roll the tapes of what we
edited out of the Carlos episode that
should be a patreon there's no new
content you have to pay for a year just
to see this one we have
content that has been shelved there's a
third Hawaii episode
I gave away that my I did like a
clothing giveaway and I was like this uh
this could have been seen on an episode
that never aired like thread out of the
audience we do have only one episode
that never aired we should
we should be thinking about what how
we'll cash in on that I think we should
do what Bobby and Santino did which is
sorry this I have banana both in my
cheeks this is what it sounds like when
you're talking to someone while blowing
them yeah hold on this is so nice
so
so like we should do Bobby and said too
okay because we'll call it a podcast
just saying talking [ __ ] about everybody
but you kept it involved
Esther's like more attract to do it's so
weird why is this
no Annie's right there is a sea uh crab
shorty we don't take care of our oceans
and something else happened guys it's
crazy well something really sad happened
well I'll tell you about your free hot
and juicy went out of business I'm gonna
kill myself what did hot and juicy and
Hollywood is gone it's gone we've never
been there I've been there and she
bought me my that was my present that I
loved I screamed about you got me my oh
my God I'm so sorry condolences brownie
I'm not driving to Orange County
honestly I'm really sad for you as
someone who's gone through this where
your favorite food goes out of business
or like moving cream Savers it's hot
yeah it no it is hard things get
discontinued like also moving from you
know Skokie to La we don't have
potbellies here we don't have Famous
Dave's where they make a really good
salad with barbecue sauce as the
dressing like there's a lot of things
that I still think about that I miss you
know what's going to get canceled soon
[ __ ] oxygen we breathe not to get
real I'm on everybody oh my God can we
put sad music and not have Al Gorey pop
his head in I I have friends who send me
the most depressing podcasts like at
three in the morning over here dude Gene
Hong sent me this the most depressing
one and it's about yeah at 3am
and and
so he sent me this thing about how with
with the shift of um everyone wanting or
moving towards like electric vehicles
those batteries are very difficult to
make because they require a lot of Hope
don't talk [ __ ] on my Tesla Gene [ __ ] up
so shut the [ __ ] up
so they took my crab legs you keep my
Tesla out of your [ __ ] but I think
I'm gonna smack you like Will Smith this
ties into your crab legs um crisis what
if the the answer is we have to just
feed crab legs into our gas tanks
it feeds into your crab legs crisis
because appearance
in order
they have to still mine for these metals
like manganese and whatnot to create the
batteries for electric cars but we're
running out on land and they have now
discovered that there are these things
in the seabed called nodules and they're
basically little like battery packs but
they have to be mined underwater so now
people are like oh we're just gonna mine
the sea bed the ocean which produces
like up to 80 percent of the oxygen we
breathe and so I'm like it's [ __ ]
over do you know what's so funny the
idea of someone sending me an article
and me actually reading it and like
absorbing the information and repeating
it to anyone like if you send me an
article of good [ __ ] luck send it to
kalylash maybe she'll explain it you did
good with the Nick crawl one though I
actually bought a subscription to New
York Times to read it and then I was so
annoyed by it do you want to know why it
annoys me like which they had
sentimental moments like that's not I'm
like you don't you are a journal so you
don't decide what someone does it's
their hour to do whatever they want yeah
and you can't be the same publication
that was saying that Nanette was like
the new wave of Comedy and the whole
point of Nanette that everyone was
fighting about was that she was being so
[ __ ] serious in it so what is it I
swear most critics it's like they're
it's just they're angry at the person
and it's their Journal we're literally
reading people's [ __ ] like dear diary
dear diary negro's dad's Ranch
these nepo babies oh these white men
it's like shut up a white guy riding the
[ __ ] you [ __ ] absolute loser I
don't know what your [ __ ] name is but
[ __ ] you and honestly it's like I feel
like I should look at this as like a win
because he's almost it's like he's
pandering to women too because he's like
these women did it so perfectly blah
blah blah it's like he's like Jenna
Freeman did it pregnant it's like you
could make an argument that all the
women are attacking to do a special
pregnant do you know what I mean it's
like but I don't think you should
because it's whatever the [ __ ] you want
in your special it's whatever you want
and it's like you're just some guy it's
like I don't know I just feel like to be
like you can't talk about your kids it's
like such a weird thing it's what is so
weird about it and I understand that
like having you know critics in general
is like a necessary good part of things
like because people will you're allowed
to go do that yeah I'm allowed to tell
you [ __ ] you totally Carlos no
mine has the spots again no it doesn't I
got them yesterday why are you yelling
and like taking away oh my God half of
it oh so are they supposed to look like
that
they do have the spots but maybe it's
just the oil like maybe it's okay I'll
try it it's probably good time you
should get us the jar okay of olives and
not these like whatever I'll eat look
fancy
and they were purchased 24 hours ago
years all right if kalila dies tomorrow
we'll know oh they taste fine are you
gonna [ __ ] her scorps you know what her
squirts yeah diarrhea don't act like
that's not something that would be
attractive to you yeah well no you look
like you'd be there's like the madman I
could just see that hair just on top of
our Corpses
wait were you about to say one time
you're having sex with a girl while she
did she was dead she passed out during
and I had to make a rape judgment call
like one that would change my life
forever you know what
um what did you do the body in the river
oh my God this is her Russian uh pimp
was downstairs and I was like I don't
know what's going on a prostitute
Carlos Carlos have you ever [ __ ]
someone you didn't pay no but because um
Okay no Okay but because she passed out
I smoked a cigarette like out like in
the room you blew it did you did you
give her CBR by blowing the smoke in her
mouth no but I was like alarmed I was
like is she dead well this happened to
me what the [ __ ] wait what
um I was in a relationship with a boy
Esther have you ever paid a guy to [ __ ]
you right I would I would do I would do
oh my God all day long except I don't
like um really I can think of some guys
I'd make offers too no what wait hang on
name names
no it's a joke it's a joke okay so one
time I went on this first date
and it was with this guy in Chicago and
like it was really great like I he was
so cute like I liked him we like went on
a walk it was really nice and then of
course me wait actually waved euclaved
no I'm like this is really a weird story
because I for some reason insisted on
sleeping over on the first date and and
he said no he no he I slept over but
what but what was his how do you insist
I think I was just like that implies
there was an immediate no and you I
think I don't remember specifically but
in my head I'm thinking like we were
just hanging out and I was like oh just
sleep here and we didn't he did not make
a move on me
but in the middle of the night we both
woke up and made out yeah we just made
out though yes but that makeout was very
hot and then I remember I specifically
left my socks there to be like oh like
what to get him in trouble for
pedophilia are you serious they were
very small they're the tiniest socks you
have ever did live no oh yeah but they
were very small I actually believe that
you're I don't think that you're
um I feel like you don't have a stinky
[ __ ] thank you I feel like you don't
have a stinky feet I think your [ __ ]
and your mouth probably have similar
things happening it's really just no my
mouth is the big problem so for smell
um so I left my socks there because I
was like I had so much fun on this first
date we had such a hot make out like
just to guarantee like he has to hit me
up
nothing imagine a guy thought like you
needed your socks back though it's like
you should leave a ring or something I'm
like I should I should yeah
and they're baby socks they're like
[ __ ] five dollars you probably didn't
even think they were yours he's probably
like this this is like uh for dogs or
something for a puppy little puppies in
the rain wait but let's do this I got
complete like where are the other two I
got complete radio silence right and
then four years later I'm standing
outside The Comedy Store doing whatever
I get a text from him
and it's like I saw your post about the
Holocaust Museum thank you for sharing
that
I was like what I just never responded
because I was so mad I don't want to
like stay on a theme of a joke I've
already made but maybe when he saw your
socks he thought of like
um like a holocaust babies like
a little baby shoes and socks like maybe
he actually donated them I have his
number one day we should call him and be
like do you still have my socks I gotta
think of whose numbers I have it was
over 13 years ago the last time we
called one of my friends it was like
such a nightmare
um I feel embarrassed by that story no
no no what's embarrassing about it
you're so embarrassing a story that
makes sense over on a first date that's
so Esther you four sleepovers on us
every day there was a there was a
baseball player I was Hardcore crushing
on in college it's already a better
story than you asked
and yours was a holocaust this is really
sad
yours was a big fan of the Holocaust
Museum this one he was like a tour guide
at the Holocaust Museum
oh my God and um anyways um he came back
to my place but I knew that he wasn't
necessarily attracted to me I wasn't his
type I think he liked the All-American
like guys
and I was not that I was um but he came
back
um nonetheless and we made out all night
we didn't sleep together but in the
morning he kept calling me Malaysia
and I didn't have the heart to tell him
that I was kalila and so Malaysia yes so
there's a boy out there a hot
ex-baseball player who was saying this
one time I hooked up with a girl
Malaysia and that was me and I didn't
say like hey my name's Kyle I was so
embarrassed that we had just had this
great night together and he didn't even
know my name do you think he was calling
you that like after the missing plane
this was pre-crash like the feelings
he's like yeah he's like my feelings
aren't here a lot like the Malaysian
plane I won't be able to find you
tomorrow yes uh yeah so that really made
me sad like even if he was searching for
me today he couldn't find me no he
couldn't find you how you're famous
um no you're famous in a world yeah but
if he's not in the comedy world like but
it would be funny if he one day like
someone is watching tiger belly or trash
Tuesday and he's like Malaysia I assume
everyone I know is not watching the
stuff I do it's like crazy the stuff I'm
just throwing out I have no I'm like oh
[ __ ] are you watching this my bad well
you kind of can't really authentically
do this job if you have in the back of
your mind that people you know are
watching yeah like it's hard enough that
my parents watch and I have to know that
I try to forget that a lot lately I've
been good at it talking about sex but it
you gotta just pretend lock it up you
can see this you know that's a really
interesting thing that we do that might
like I wonder how this plays out in 20
years like when we look back and like
those people were really good at
pretending they were just in a room with
each other and yet they had a whole
audience like kind of
um
um you know having thoughts about what
we're saying but we're so blocked off
well I have to look at the camera to
remember I have to be like guys like
there's another like there's another
person here that's thousands of people
do you know what I mean like I have to
like look at the camera and be like
or it's done now
I had a guy that I was hooking up with
okay
who coincidentally was the one that gave
me crab so he was actually the STD boy
is he is he our hero he is
I is he still Doling out crabs let me
see if I have his number
I had it like since I moved to L.A
because I remember I texted him to like
not like in a sexual way and it pissed
me off because he went sorry my my
buying dinner in exchange for sex is
done I was like that's you dude I stayed
friends after gave me crabs dinner in
exchange I was like what I [ __ ] you
when I was 21 and I've stayed friends
with you for like eight years what the
hell are you talking about you know this
is why I actually really like Snoop Dogg
because he normalized crabs for me in
high school and he took away all the
fear I had about it um he was he was on
um big boy on Power 106 and he was asked
the question about STD and you can
either pass or you can answer truthfully
but if you pass there was like a
consequence and he talked about having
crabs and he called him little soldiers
and they all laughed about it and you
know I was like oh maybe it's not so bad
and I stopped fearing crabs I never got
crabs but I mean I would be open
oh my God okay wait that's why I'm
asking if her friend still Doling them
out because are they even still I never
hear about them do they die off are they
still out there
a crab still a thing he's an A.D on
Hunger Games you're doing all right okay
I have my hot dogs that's pretty good
it's still around oh okay wait look at
this guy
this is the guy that gave me clothes
crabs are going extinct no I always
think that like to do like a picket like
outside of the Rite Aid like don't know
more rid because it's head lice I think
that we should definitely be our guy on
the show
oh he's cute oh he's crab guy yeah oh
crab guy does not look like crab guy
yeah he's hot no that's why he was like
you cannot be telling people that makes
her own hair I like what you did
he's a pharmacist no no he's like a
assistant director on big movies he's
like doing great and you're showing
everyone his photos
we learned that there are two crab
crises that were currently the right
we're trying to bring them all back
right so
um we're losing crabs guys both sexually
transmitted crabs and crabs from the
ocean and this is a really big big deal
and this is our platform that we're
running for Miss America on We're Gonna
Save the crabs save the crabs you guys
this is so sad I looked up his Twitter
and he'll save hot and juicy 36
followers I thought you were gonna say
he's dead no oh my God you know it could
be
anyone that's been inside me has is at
risk
you guys thank you so much for being a
part of this this was a chaotic overly
sexual I know what the hell am I no are
you kidding it's just a nice friendly
wholesome crabby episode you guys thank
you so much as always
subscribe
subscribe like comment us we love weird
nothing without we're nothing without
you we're something without you that's
I'm nothing without you Esther's nothing
hi guys
foreign
[Music]